according to the molar indictment after
the twenty six elections Russians
organized anti-trump rallies which were
then breathlessly covered by a hopeful
CNN and MSNBC NBC's Morgan Radford is at
Union Square in New York City that is
where the anti-trump protest is just
about to kick off I want to show you
some of the signs and the posters
they're holding up here you can see one
here that says knowledge Trump's hate
protect our public schools teachers
against Trump
yells we're not going to be tolerating
any sexism or homophobia this is
something different it's something
unique the energy here is electric there
are thousands of people right now taking
over Fifth Avenue with several messages
although aimed at our president-elect it
is the most organized protest that I've
seen happen here in New York City
because it's organized by Russians okay
now we ran a short clip of the same
protest but at least we showed some
restraint
the point is Russia's able to yank
America's chain by picking at our own
existing team-sport mentality they don't
really need to organize these rallies we
hated each other already but when one
angry group won't accept an election how
could the Russians resist like a global
Iago they spread rumors to undermine all
sides and the media of course as you can
tell lapse it up so here's a tip don't
trust the Russians I know talk about
breaking news but every conservative
awake in the 1970s knew this and that's
what kills me about the left Russia is a
fraction of what they were during the
Cold War
and now the Democrats are worried
decades ago when the right fiercely
challenged the USSR the left aided the
Soviets leading the anti anti-communist
charge meanwhile communist influence
helped propel American protests at
rallies backing every left-wing cause
charming every dumb celebrity on the
left they didn't mind at all better to
be on Joe Stalin side than Joe
McCarthy's so now they're mad about the
Russian screw him
they're like the guy who offers to help
you move apartments but shows up what
it's already done and the pizzas arrive
sorry we don't need to anymore all the
heavy liftings been done I hate you you
have professional movers Kimberly
I know I apologize for that yes either I
keep all the shoes all right Dana I have
a huge theory on this in my mind what
changed America permanently it was the
Vietnam War and according to stanislav
faloona who was a Russian defector
Soviet Union gave a hundred billion
dollars to American anti-war movements
and that created we weren't that split
our country wasn't split until then and
then they they infused a billion dollars
into the anti-war movements and to a lot
of other peace movements they have been
so many shadow organizations with the
word peace in it we split in the Vietnam
War and through the 70s it continued we
never ever came back we never healed and
I believe the Russians USSR the biggest
victory they've ever had was creating
that division during the Vietnam War and
this stuff that we're seeing that that
the media ate up these protests that's
nothing compared to what we've been
through for 50 years
that is a great theory thank you what
country is doing that now in a different
way what China who these Confucius
centers that they have at all these
universities yes the country
little by little there are some
universities starting to reject that but
that is happening the other thing is
interesting on the media side of this is
that it was a very different story in
France last year they had an election as
well and Emmanuel macron ordered the
media not to I'm sorry the Electoral
Commission ordered the media not to
cover any of the leaked emails right and
they could be prosecuted that would
never happen here because we have a
First Amendment but it was a very
different story there they were able to
block Russia from doing it because they
were able to band together and say you
know we're gonna put France first yeah
pretty much is what ended up happening
there and so in in what the media did is
they did they have some complicity in
unwitting yeah yes
I'm winning useful idiots and sowing the
chaos right I like your theory about
Vienna what one you're slightly older
than me
you remember how conservatives in the
70s were mocked for the Russian under
every bed remember there's a Russian
under every bed it was considered
hysteria
fundamentally we were right all along
about the Russian influence our
influence at least on campus and and in
all of these anti-war movements correct
I don't remember it that way but I mean
just reading back I mean you what you
cited Joe McCarthy is very real and
traumatizing for the American body
politic in the 50s that someone would be
identifying blacklisting people labeling
them as having communist associations
you look back at the civil rights
movement dr. King so many of his
associates even King himself the attack
was so what happened was a communist so
what happens is you take people who are
anti-communist and you place it in the
same I guess lump is Joe McCarthy no I
think that what you have to do is when
you say people are anti-communist you
have to take them seriously because I
think most Americans are anti commies
most Americans the left was anti
anti-communist
I think they were saying if you go to
extremes here you're going to damage
people's lives and career everyone
commie window and kind of you know
smearing them but my feeling is on this
one I mean I read that Michael Moore was
in attendance at that so tests that use
showed us so but my feeling is that you
get this in the aftermath of the
overwhelming effort by the Russians to
sow the discontent the discord to appeal
to one side or another
and so here Trump wins the election
they're gonna now force all of a sudden
the anti-trump because all I want is to
destabilize us lose trust our
institutions lose trust all around yeah
so but so Hawaii isn't Trump doing
anything now now you're just playing
into it by saying why isn't Trump doing
I think the press your thing about the
press is wild to me if the press didn't
cover all those leaks of the Podesta
males and the Clinton speeches you said
they're covering for Hillary I don't
know about that I want to get you know I
actually disagree with you but go
Kimberly yeah so I'm the the thing here
is this Russians been doing this you
know forever right this is what they've
been doing is nothing new this isn't
something that they came up with like
you know last year to decide to try to
create like chaos in American politics
they thrive on disinformation campaigns
where they want put one side against
each other and they'll flip to the other
side they have
no loyalty they bear no allegiance
except to their own cause so today
perhaps you know they go for okay Pro
jump tomorrow they go anti-trump because
they want everything in total disarray
so that's the bottom line but again I go
back to the point which is I think the
media was very complicit in this because
they seized upon it like a mouse with
cheese trying to like gobble it up
because they liked the idea of it
because it fit their narrative that they
already had built in with their bias
towards President Trump now there and at
the time candidate Trump and that's why
you saw the minute the man was sworn in
more continuation of Russian collusion
and Trump Tower and what kind of Nexus
was there between anybody working in his
campaign and the Russians everything -
then maybe shifted to the next chapter
which was let's deal Ajith amis the
American presidency which is of course
also playing into the hands of the
Russians so the media then became a pawn
in this Russian chess emails being
covered were Hillary's emails yes and by
the way to your point I was I was at
this table
Juan saying that we we had a
responsibility not to not to cover this
yes all right but then I hear you today
it's that you're saying the press was a
pawn and I'm thinking the press
especially the New York Times they were
all over Hillary she's on the basis of
the Russian show how breathless they
were there I guess she's falling asleep
here excuse me yes the only thing that
the American media looked like Pravda
they got duped and they unwittingly
keyword created with the Russia but you
with me you so I agree you know who
wittingly colluded Hillary you know who
also wittingly colluded knowing random
shift yeah just to put this into
perspective this rally had a what tens
of thousands of people this was an
anti-trump sponsored rally by the
Russians the other sponsored Russian
rallies for Trump dozens showed up so
this was the biggest thing they did and
it was anti Trump all right